so Christmas is coming just a few days
and we have a present for you
I can take no credit for this whatsoever
it's the Geniuses on our producing staff
who did this it's part of a Tucker
Carlson's original on Fox Nation and
here's part of what they've made for you
it's time ladies and gentlemen for your
favorite Christmas game
what did Joe just say think about what
you'd think about at the time
Brock and I think it's a right for
people that bad it can't prepare for
people that bad and can't care
repeat the line I'll lead an effective
strategy to mobilize true International
pressure through an international
pressure go end up quote repeat the line
America is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
I was the foot of foot
look
I don't care you know
what for you all on Montana that ain't
mine you know but there's a man on the
moon or whatever you know something or
you know whether those aliens are here
or not then I mean no no but I mean
think of I mean it's not about I know
you're a supplemental so my physical as
well as my mental Fitness
away it's my little sister Valerie and
I'm Jill's husband oh no there you go oh
you switched on me it's my wife this is
my sister they switched on me why
doesn't he just act like a president
that's a stupid way to say it you know
Donald Trump
sorry
go ahead
no no I probably best I don't well I'm
sick and tired of smart guys it is what
it is because he is who he is
foreign
you think you've seen them all but you
haven't
even I hadn't seen them all our guys
really dug it's it's amazing
it's a digital short and Tucker Carlson
Originals it's out right now on Fox
Nation and we recommend it for levity's
sake
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight